I got it
so I are you guys gonna mute when I talk
so so nothing interrupts it because once
I'm in the floor once I'm in the floor I
like to stay in the flow having some
type of support it's very necessary when
you're creative you know there has to be
something that's fueling that creativity
that's fueling that fire that you have
inside my love for music and creativity
starts way back way back back in the
South Bronx where I grew up
building 700 apartment 2e I will go
outside and all I would hear is music
you go around to the back park the DJ's
are playing it's a basketball game going
on but then you would look at the
handball court and that handball court
have a amazing graffiti mural I don't
know if it's from Keith Haring or fab 5
Freddy I was instantly attracted to the
creative music has been my therapy since
day one anytime I get stressed out I go
to the Arts I go to creativity I go to
music music make people feel hugged
people feel loved and then I remember
one of my uncles saying you should get
into producing like what's producing you
know it started as a family-owned
business because Rough Riders was
created by my family gave you DMX it
gave you Eve it gave you drag on it gave
you the LOX I've gotten every accolade
in music that one can get it just came
to the point where it's like you know
what I'm no longer gonna have fun with
this unless I'm able to give back you
know the Dean collection started for me
to create a museum for my family and our
name something that my kids would have
to be responsible the pastor generations
so wait a minute the Dean collection is
not just for the Dean collection the
Dean collection is for everyone there's
some galleries now in place as you walk
in if you don't have 50,000 there's
nothing to talk about
and I felt that a lot of people was
using that as an excuse to exit art they
feel that art is only for rich people
whoa whee
stop this we got to fix this and that's
what made me and my wife say you know we
have to create an entry point to the
younger generation that didn't
understand the art world didn't have
that seat at the table and then we
started no commissions it's a big event
you got 30-something thousand RSVPs at
night the drinks are free the food is
free the concerts free the education is
free and I feel that education should be
free we went to Shanghai we went to
London we went to Berlin we did it right
in my backyard in the South Bronx you
can come into no commissions and get
something for a couple of bucks or a
couple of hundred thousand did there's a
tear for every person that have love for
art and what we're doing is something
totally different from a gallery the
artists keep 100% of the sales but what
about after no Commission's how can you
sustain how can you move forward without
having to be trapped to sell your soul I
was a part of the sale with my brother
Sean Diddy Combs the 21 million dollar
purchase which may carry James ma shoe
the highest selling african-american
living artists to today I'm like man
like you just broke the record and the
heart is like yeah I don't know whether
to be happy or to be sad he first saw
that work it was under a hundred
thousand so imagine a work that you made
for under a hundred thousand is now
being sold for twenty-one million and
you have to sit home and watch this and
you couldn't even participate 5% when
you look at it I'm a producer I'm a
songwriter every time is played on a
radio I get paid every time it's played
in a movie I get paid every time it
plays period
I get paid visual artists they only get
paid once how when paintings are sold
and traded multiple times and that's
that artists lifetime work that other
people are making 10 15 sometimes a
hundred times more than the artists that
created it so
I created something called the danger I
swear if you're a seller or collector
and you're bringing your work into let's
say Sotheby's there's a paper that's
there to say hey guys you know this
artist is still living you've made three
hundred percent on your investment by
working with this artist you can choose
to give the artist whatever you want of
the sale I think that even if five
people who did it it has started to
change everything and in the arts and
this is happening in Europe already it
happens in the music industry it's
called publishing and artists are able
to survive musicians are able to survive
years after years offered a residual
income of their publishing so how can we
take something that brings creatives
together and celebrate each other
myself and Timberland been working on
this idea called versus for about three
years now
then this trying time came and everybody
started going to social media to express
themselves so what we did was I played
my top songs he played his top songs and
we went on Instagram live a lot of
people like to say battle we pulled back
off for that word batter because we're
battling enough in the world today we
call it an educational celebration I
think we on our 9th or 10th one me and
Timbaland started out with 20,000 people
as of yesterday 750,000 people in one
room so we have this thing called the
vs. effect and the vs. effect is what
happened to the artists after they
contribute two verses we can go to the
babyface and Teddy rally they both went
up millions of views both of their songs
re-entered the charts and then we look
at the first lady's verses and both
Erykah Badu and Joe Scott have seven
positions in the top 20 charts this is
the vs. effect you know billions and
billions and
of impressions this is something I've
never seen before and I felt that these
artists are getting their flowers today
which is a great thing why they can
smell them this is personal for me
because many a times I've been counted
out
I've been hot and cold a hundred times
you still have to understand the
business as an artist to elevate to your
level that you deserve to be because
most creative we're very emotional
we're very let somebody else handle that
I want to stick to this but not only
creativity is key education is key which
is the reason why I went back to school
to sharpen my pencil and my mid thirties
we have to know our business but it's
going to take us digging in a little
deeper and pulling out the knowledge
that we need to prepare ourself for this
world that's waiting to take advantage
of the creatives then we can make better
choices then we can end that
conversation of artists dying poor if
we're not protecting the Arts we're not
protecting our future we're not
protecting this world creativity heals
us as these shades closing for time out
[Music]